introduction so today I'm going to be
talking about three broad techniques
that he can apply to build robust
unbiased models but before we go too
deep into this topic I just want to do a
fun exercise with all of you so there's
some awesome you know brain power here
so I want to train all of your brains to
detect in a malaria so here you have a
bunch of you know training data they are
labeled the images on the left are
infected cells and the images on the
right are uninfected cells so please
take a moment train your you know neural
networks to find some pattern that sort
of help you identify cells that are
infected so let's take a few seconds for
you guys to just go through the images
here okay all good all right cool
so I'm gonna run through some tests just
to see how well you guys did so first
test who here thinks this is an
uninfected cell a few of you the rest of
you I'm guessing are infected on the
infected camp okay
and a few of you unsure so it looks like
the uninfected camp you guys are right
the rest of you you need to like tune
your models a bit before we go to the
next test who here thinks this is an
infected cell okay that's pretty much
all of you that's amazing so your
accuracy has gone up now so it's gone up
200% it's indeed infected and last test
this is a bit tricky who here thinks
this is infected okay less a few and the
rest of you uninfected okay
turns out this is an infected cell so
those of you who said infected here
right so let's try to understand what we
just did here who here can tell me why
they thought a cell was infected can
anyone volunteer yes right so there's
like a ring like you know structure
around like a pink red any anybody else
pick up on anything else
okay yeah so it looks like the edges of
it it you know it irregular there that
that may be the case for like a lot of
other cases so that that's right
anything else color like red ping yep so
looks like all of you have like picked
up on that pattern and that's great and
so if you guys don't take away anything
else from the stock you guys are now
experts at detecting malaria so but
before that let's let's take a step back
and try to understand the process that
we just went through and I'm going to
draw parallels with how we build machine
learning models so we're gonna start off
of course with his historical data and
that's what we did we had the label data
and we were training our brains in this
case now we'll be training machine
learning models and we'll go through a
cross-validation step that's quite
iterative and this is what we're going
to do to tune our models and you're
going to evaluate the models on the
valve set and if all is good we're gonna
use that learned model to test on a
blind set of data that the model hasn't
seen before and we're gonna evaluate
this using metrics like accuracy and
there are like a whole ton of other
metrics that he could use and if the
model performance is acceptable to the
stakeholders then you would go ahead and
deploy the model into a production
system where now the model is exposed to
new data that it hasn't seen before and
here this is when things start to go
wrong this is where you may see that the
performance is not as good as when you
tested it on his historical data and
there are two main reasons for this one
is the distribution of the data may be
different now so there might be some
change in the behavior of the users of
the system or something may have
happened where the distribution has
changed so this is you know data drift
and the other is maybe the historical
data isn't you know representative of
the population so that could be some
kind of you know sampling bias this sort
of like reveals an oversight of the data
scientists who was building the model
and the other main reason is data
leakage so this is where there's some
information about the target variable
that sort of leaked while you were
training and there was like a classic
example of this in
kdd 2008 where the competition was to
detect if a cancerous cell was benign or
malignant and the winning team that got
an accuracy of close to 100% if I'm not
wrong basically used a feature which was
the patient ID and it turns out that
that contains some encoding of how
severe the condition was for the patient
and that sort of like tricked the team
into thinking they build something
wonderful and so like all of this can be
circumvented if we add this model
understanding step here and the main
reason for doing this is to just not
just look at the data more closely but
also look at what the model has learnt
and that's essentially the focus of
today's talk there's also another reason
for doing this now with the gdpr you
know right to explanation you sort of
need to like answer this question of why
the model came up with a prediction and
so this is a very hot topic there are
models that are inherently you know
transparent and a classic example of
this is a decision tree and this is you
know data said that most of you may have
seen it's essentially you're using four
features of an iris flower to detect one
of three types you're trying to classify
this into one of three types so you have
you know four filters here the petal
length battle with set of length and
supple width and I used the scikit-learn
open data set here to train a decision
tree and you can very easily visualize
this as follows and like what you see
here is it's essentially a bunch of a
Fell's conditions where you're finding
splits in the data that minimize say
entropy or maximize accuracy and you can
see that as you start from the top the
root node of the tree the condition is
if the petal length is less than 2.5
then you go to the left branch of the
tree otherwise you go through the right
branch and so on and this is like really
easy for us to follow and this is
essentially how we also think about
problems if you look at a slightly more
complex you know dataset this is looking
at the breast cancer data set there are
30 different features here and if we
train a decision tree now you get
something that's a bit more complex and
this is essentially like you know the
complexity of the tree increases as the
number of features increase and you can
of course like simplify this by
sassette setting a limit to the depth
and also pruning the tree in other ways
but this is still understandable you can
really easily understand what this model
is saying there of course other you know
transparent models that you can use that
sort of fall on the interpretable side
of the spectrum but what we're going to
be focusing on our models that are
slightly more complex that have high you
know predictive power but not so
interpretable and let's see what kind of
techniques we can apply there
so first step let's look at the data and
features and that one of the main things
that we do is to look at the feature
importance and I'm going to make a case
for going beyond that so that you get a
much deeper understanding of models so
for feature importance let's look at a
concrete example so this is the data set
that I obtained from cattle and it is a
data set of high-school students in the
US and the task is to predict the agreed
in math reading and writing and the
features that you have are these five
features which which are gender raise
the level of education for the parents
the type of lungs of the student eats
and the level of preparation for the
test and as you'd imagine when so when I
built the model the first step is of
course to encode these features and then
I've trained around a forest model to
predict the grade which could be one of
four types that's a B C or F now once
you've trained the model the accuracy
was pretty decent the next step is to
look at the future importance and that's
one of the first steps that you would do
and so looking at the feature importance
here across the board for both for math
reading and writing it looks like the
two most important features are the
parent level of Education and race or
ethnicity and this is an interesting
insight but it doesn't give us the whole
picture like what feature importance
tells us is like on a global scale
what's the average impact of each of
these features in predicting the outcome
and it does look like it gives us some
sort of information on what the two most
important features are but it doesn't
tell us how different levels of
Education impact the outcome and also
how these two features interact with
each other and this is where you can
start to look at partial
Windansea Platz and zoom into the one on
the left here just so that you can see
what's going on there so the first is
let's look at the most important feature
which is the parent level of Education
now if we want to see how different
levels of education impact the outcome
what partial dependency plots does is it
looks at these different values for the
parent level of education and assumes
that you know all of the other features
and looks at the average impact of the
each of these different values now on
the x-axis the level of education
basically increases as you go from left
to right so it starts with high school
goes all the way to the bachelor's
degree and then master's degree and you
can see that in general as the level of
education increases the impact on
predicting grade a increases and this
sort of makes sense and the model seems
to have learnt this pattern quite well
but what if we want to look at how the
parent level of education how that
interacts with race or ethnicity so this
is where you can now look at the future
interaction plot I'm looking at two
different features here on the y-axis is
the parent level of education so as you
go from bottom to top the level
increases and on the x-axis are five
different groups that you have so and
also the other thing I'm not sure if you
can see the color but a darker shade or
blue is means low impact and I like the
shade which is green or yellow means
higher impact so if we zoom into one of
these groups here you can see that as
the level of education increases the
impact on predicting grade a sort of
increases the color sort of moves from a
darker shade which is violet all the way
to like green but and and this and you
would expect to see this like you
shouldn't they shouldn't be unless these
two features are highly correlated you
would expect that regardless of the race
it should only be dependent on the level
of education and the preparation for the
test and so on but what's going on with
group four here you can see that
a parent with a high school degree has
just as much impact as a parent with a
bachelor's degree and this sort of
exposes four different problems that
could be like four different problems
here
one is that partial dependence plots
don't work very well when the features
are highly correlated so you may need to
go back and look at whether these two
features are indeed you know correlated
the other is there might be some kind of
sampling bias here where group four
isn't properly you know represented or
the model hasn't learned any pattern
here are four the fourth problem is that
there's some in a systemic problem which
becomes much harder to solve but it
turns out that in this in a dataset a
group 4 wasn't properly you know
represented and that's why you're seeing
some weird impacts here but the main
point is that none of these insights
would have been possible if we had just
looked at the future important so it's
important to let go a bit deeper and
make sure that the model has learned all
of these different patterns so things
don't go horribly wrong when you'd apply
to implement this in Python I use the
PDP box
you know library this I found to be much
better than the scikit-learn
implementation because as you would
expect P P DP should be agnostic of the
model whereas the psychical and
implementation expects you to use a
gradient boosted regression or you know
gradient booster tree implementation
whereas here you could feed at any model
and the the you know the first line here
shows you for a given feature how
different values impact the outcome and
for the second one you can feed it a
list of features to look at feature
interactions and by the way all of this
code is in the repo up there I'll you
know share the slides later on or after
the stock so you can have a look at the
code now the next technique I'm going to
talk about is post off explenation so
let's go back to the breast cancer data
set so say that you've trained this deep
you know neural network or maybe you
know random forests or a green goose a
tree and you learn this complex function
that separates
the benign class from the malignant
class and this is like really hard to
explain because it's a nonlinear
function you have no idea what's what
it's doing so one way to simplify this
is to pick one instance that you want to
explain so here let's look at say one
malignant case that you want to explain
let's put up the features to look at
cases around it assuming that they share
similar properties and you fit a linear
model around it that's sort of faithful
to all of the data points around that
instance that you want to explain and
because you're training a you know a
linear model it's much easier to explain
because it's a transparent model you can
just look at the weights of the
explanation parameters and that sort of
gives you an indication of how do cases
that are similar to that behave and this
is basically the theory behind line
which stands for local interpretable
model agnostic explanations and this is
another view of it so you have data that
you learn a complex function then you
pick in an instance X prime and you
train a linear model G that sort of
approximates the complex function f
around that point X prime and the
parameters of this model are sort of the
explenation parameters and that's shown
here we're going to be looking at an
improvement align cap the the
implementation is better as well and the
explanations that you get seem a lot
better than the lime explanations so
going back to the breast cancer data set
you have you know 30 features here I've
trained a random forest model that
predicts whether it's malignant or
benign I'll show the code later on the
you know the accuracy is pretty good and
then I use the tree explainer class from
the shop library to explain one instance
like this so again I'll show the code
just so that this becomes clear so
switching to my notebook so this is the
repository up on github I'm running the
shaft tree ensembles notebook locally
right now
so here you can see that first I'm
loading the breast cancer data set from
scikit-learn
these are all of the features splitting
it into train and test and using
cross-validation to pick the best
hyperparameters here and looking at the
best model evaluating on the test set
you get an average precision of a
hundred percent which is awesome and
then the next step is once you've
installed the shop library here which is
easy to install using pip you then
initialize the three explainer class
initialize it with the model that you've
trained and you generate shop values for
all of the instances in your test set
okay now here what I'm doing is this
line of code is basically explaining the
first instance in the test set sorry
this is the this is the first instance
in the test set and it turns out to be a
malignant case and what you can see is
that the base rate is roughly at in a
sixty two percent and you can see how
each of these feature values push the
base prediction up to ninety percent
which was the final you know accuracy
for that case and what you can see is
that the red the you know the red color
here means that it has a positive impact
and blue means it has a negative impact
and the larger the width that means more
the impact so features like the worst
concave points and mean concave points
these values sort of push this all the
way up to 90% at the end and what this
is good for is you can very easily
deploy this or before you deploy it you
can test this using an actual expert so
if you have a human in the loop you can
show each of these examples and look at
how the model arrived at the final
outcome here looking at a benign case
again here I'm just looking at the
probability that it's a malignant cell
and here it's basically you know 0% so
the probability of being benign is
and you can see how each of these values
pushes the base rate down to zero at the
end you can also look at a summary plot
which shows the average in fact over all
of the cases in the test set and again
the two most important features here are
the worst concave points and mean
concave points and you can also look at
feature interaction similar to the PDP
plots that I showed earlier so what this
shows is different values for the worst
concave points plotted against different
values for the mean concave points red
means positive impact blue means
negative impact now you can see that
higher values for worse concave points
and higher values for mean concave
points have much stronger impact and
predicting that the case is malignant
whereas lower values have lower impact
and predicting that smiley that it's
malignant so these are these are just
like another tool that he can use to
like get a much deeper understanding of
what the model has learned you can of
course use shop to look at deep learning
models so here I'm using the amnesty no
data set train the convolution neural
network and then use the shaft defects
planar class to come up with an
explanation like this so here I'm
basically looking at you know a super
pixel so converted the raw pixels into a
super pixel and looking at the impacts
just to simplify the problem for the
deep explainer look look at what impact
the super pixel has on predicting each
of these you know digits and let's zoom
into one case here so if you look at
digit zero what this shows is that
pixels that sort of form the digit zero
have a strong impact in predicting that
and also the lack of ink in the middle
also has a strong impact in predicting
digit zero similarly for for the lack of
a connection between the top two lines
sort of why this makes it a four and not
a nine and this is basically an
explanation for this just looking at
cases that are around it and this is
interesting but this doesn't work well
all of the time because you know the
decision boundary may not be as good as
these two cases here this was like a
cherry picked example but like for cases
at least this leg gives you a bit more
insight into what the model is learning
we're just looking at cases around it
okay so the last technique I want to
talk about how you can mitigate bias if
it does exist so if the model has
somehow implicitly learned to say subtle
biases in the data how do you deal with
that and the picture here is of this
researcher joy Bala meanie who basically
started this algorithmic justice league
and she's like out to fight bias and
algorithms I would highly recommend
listening to her TED talk where she
found biases in like face detection
algorithms where like these algorithms
were much better at detecting white
faces and black faces and so this was
like a serious problem that was exposed
and so that just so that you don't have
to deal with it when you're building
your models let's like look at
techniques that he can use to mitigate
it so one technique that I've been
recently looking at is adversarially
biasing so this was a paper that came
out of Stanford and Google the main idea
here is you're basically training an
adversarial network here the first
network is the predictor network that
predicts the target variable the second
network is an adverse feat right that
tries to predict a protected variable
and one of what this you know protected
variable means is basically a variable
that is a proxy for a feature that
you're trying to unbias so if you want a
model that isn't biased towards a given
race or a given gender then you would
use the particular variable to somehow
capture that feature and what the
predictor is trying to do is you're
going to update the weights of the
predictor in such a way that you throw
the adversary off in being able to
predict
that variable that you know protected
variable so the idea here is the
adversary shouldn't be better than say
randomly picking a gender so that's
basically what the predictor is trying
to do so this is sort of the theory
behind adversarial training and that's
essentially what this architecture is
trying to do and we are going to be
focusing on one of these the definitions
of fairness where basically the
prediction is independent of the
predicted variable so let's look at a
concrete example just to make this clear
so if we look at the word embedding
analogy tasks so embeddings are a
powerful mechanism for projecting
discreet words into a real subspace so
basically the dimension of a real
subspace would be much less than the
number of words in your corpus and one
algorithm that you can look at is the
Skip Graham algorithm which basically
looks at context of words around it to
predict the given word and unfortunately
like using the corpus that it that you
use did are depending on the corpus that
you use it could so if you look at this
analogy task which is he is she as
doctor is to what you start to see cases
like where woman mother pregnant sort of
like show up in the the top set of words
here and this is clearly showing some
kind of like implicit bias in the corpus
that the model has picked up on so how
do you deal with this clearly the task
here is to find a profession that sort
of is you know gender-neutral here or
you want to like find a gender-neutral
answer here so I've been trying to
reproduce this paper using this notebook
here adversarially biasing this can be
found on my github repo if you go to the
adversarially biasing branch this is
still a work in progress but if anybody
wants to help out please feel free this
is the link to the paper and this
notebook is based on another notebook
that is that implements the same
algorithm but I've made some minor
tweaks and made
battable with python free so the first
step is of course installing jensen so
that you can easily load were to back
embeddings and i'm basically loading the
google news were to back file here and
the first lines of code basically
looking at this analogy tasks and seeing
what answers come up using the current
embeddings that we learned and this is
the output that i showed earlier now the
next step is to define the protected
variable of embedding so we need some
representation of gender so what you can
do is you can look at pairs of words
that clearly the difference between them
is clearly just the gender so if you
look at woman man her has she he and so
on these clearly the difference between
them would sort of like the strong
feature here is the gender so it just
looked at the difference between these
pairs of words
apply PCA till I come up with a vector
that represents the gender direction and
that's shown here and essentially what
the adversary is trying to do is is
trying to like maximize the projection
of all of these words onto the gender
direction so that it's task is basically
to predict the gender and what the
predictor is trying to do is is trying
to throw the throw off the adversary so
that it gets really bad at that task and
that's essentially the adversary model
training section here the main thing to
note is that when you are training an
adversarial network it's quite tricky
it's quite you know sensitive to the
learning rate so I picked a very low
learning rate here of course you can you
can play around with this to see what
results you get but these were the
hyperparameters that were that that I
used and after training if you look at
this analogy task now you start to see
words that sort of define the profession
rather than just random words that are
sort of similar in context so you start
to see you know gynecologist physician
pediatrician and so on that come up as
much with a much higher score and of
course like one thing that I'm
struggling with is to know when you're
done when you know that you've sort of
like removed all of the possible bias
and that I realize is not possible it
says you can just like mitigate as much
of this as possible so the way that I
was thinking of doing was getting some
kind of human in the loop to like
understand or gauge how well this new
model has learned this analogy tasks and
so that's the the last technique and of
course this isn't everything suggests to
summarize here so we we want to include
model understanding into our data
science process so that we can gain a
much deeper understanding and not have
not deal with these embarrassing
situations of poor model performance our
biases that the models are exposing be
mindful of your audience like
interpretability means different things
to different people for like us are like
majority of us it sort of is to build
better models but again if it's a
business stakeholder it's so that they
gain more confidence in what the model
is doing so you can hand over more tasks
to it you can of course apply these
interpretability techniques to again
there's no silver bullet here you need
to look at it from different angles to
gain a much deeper understanding so
apply these tools and it'll like help
you with your modeling process and
finally use the adversarial D biasing
technique if you can to mitigate bias
again here we've only looked at the
supervised learning a problem for
unsupervised learning or any other type
of scenario this is that still an active
area of research and there's not much
but again this is a good start for us
and in terms of additional resources
I've written a blog post on this which
sort of covers what I just
talked about all of the source code
isn't that github repo there are of
course other techniques that he can use
and there are links to this that I've
provided here two pages of this the book
the last bullet point here is also great
there's of course the counterfactual
explanation so wish I had more time to
go through all of this but again these
are links for you to get more
information and with that that's the end
of the talk I'm going to open it up to a
few questions if you have any
[Applause]
no I mean so that's yeah the thing is I
haven't in this example here but then
like one thing that you may have noticed
is that nurse still turns up as the top
word even if like how much ever you try
to like if you want to believe that that
that shouldn't be the top word but it
turns out that the context always
contains doctor and nurse in in the same
context so you can't you know so
circumvent that problem just because
doctor and nurse sort of appeared
together so it's not showing the genders
to your type it's just showing that
doctrine those are sort of very similar
in context or they appear together so
there has to be a better way of learning
these embeddings rather than just
looking at the context or semantics you
know similarity here but yeah that's an
interesting problem I haven't looked
into it
[Music]
no no I mean you can still use line I
mean it's sort of essentially like all
of these different techniques are like
additive explanations so they use the
same framework it's just how you come up
with the explanation parameters that's
what it's different like shap you
Shapley values whereas lime uses a
linear model so there's not to say that
one technique is better than the other
but it's just from a visualization
standpoint I sort of felt sharp gave
much better visualizations than the
lying implementation and so that's what
I've gone with and the shop paper sort
of gives a framework that sort of covers
lying other techniques like deep lift
and so on and so it's you can use any of
those techniques as part of the shop
library that I'm using so it's not just
that I preferred shop because it's a
better algorithm it's just because it
encapsulate all of them
okay yeah that's a very good question
I haven't tried that I want to after the
stock but yeah that that is a good
question here so I know that that there
are like people who prefer gams mainly
because it gives a high you know
predictive power at the same time it's
interpretable I haven't like personally
used them but they're of course that are
like a lot of libraries out there that
have come out from various people that
implement gam as well as ji-ji-ji A to M
which is an implementation of gams that
look at interactions between features
and not just look at functions of one
feature alone so there are these
different implementations that he can
look at I think da to M were shown to be
a lot more powerful than Gauss's but
yeah I wish I could talk more about it
but yeah that's that's certainly one
technique that you can use
[Applause]